>> Emily: WELCOME BACK.
THERE ARE SOME GRIM NEW NUMBERS
FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN WHEN IT
COMES TO THE BORDER.
VOTERS IN THE NEW FOX POLL SAY
BORDER SECURITY IS WORSE TODAY
THAN IT WAS TWO YEARS AGO.
ALL THIS SMUGGLERS HAVE BEEN
CAUGHT IN A NEW VIDEO NOW USING
A ROPE TO LOWER A MOTHER AND HER
KID DOWN THIS 30-FOOT SECTION OF
BORDER WALL.
MEANTIME, VICE PRESIDENT HERE IS
COMING UP WITH THIS EXCUSE WHEN
PRESSED ON WHY SHE HASN’T
VISITED THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT HAS BEEN A MONTH SINCE SHE
WAS MADE THE POINT PERSON FOR A
RECORD SURGE IN MIGRANTS.
>> YES, WE ARE WORKING ON A
PLANE TO GET THERE.
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH COVID
ISSUES, BUT I CAN GET THERE SOON
ENOUGH IN TERMS OF PERSONALLY
GETTING THERE.
>>>> Emily: JOE CONCHA, WE HAVE
TO GO WITH THE COVID ISSUE.
THAT IS A DIFFERENT STORY THAN
EVEN WHAT SHE CAMPAIGNED ON
WHERE SHE MADE A FOCAL POINT
ABOUT "MAKING MEANINGFUL CHANGE
TO IMMIGRATION AND ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION," SO WHAT HAPPENED
TO HER PET PASSION?
>> Joe: VERY GOOD QUESTION,
EMILY.
SHE IS FULLY VACCINATED.
THE VICE PRESIDENT IS VIEWED IS
ON THE CDC SAY IT IS OKAY TO
TRAVEL WHEN YOU ARE FULLY
VACCINATED?
SHE HAS GONE TO EIGHT OR NINE
OTHER STATES.
TAXES NOT ON THAT PARTICULAR
SCHEDULE, SO THAT EXCUSES OUT.
BY THE WAY, IN THAT POLL, WHO
ARE THE 15% THAT THINK THAT
THINGS ARE BETTER AT THE BORDER?
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE?
TO QUOTE JERRY SEINFELD.
KAMALA HARRIS ENDS UP BEING ON
THE TOP OF THE TICKET.
EVEN SOME DEMOCRATS SAY THAT
THAT MAY BE THE CASE.
BIDEN MAY BE A ONE-TERM
PRESIDENT HE OR SHE WILL HAVE TO
RUN ON HER RECORD AS
VICE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS HER NUMBER ONE PRIORITY.
HOW DO YOU THINK THE PROBLEM
WHEN YOU DON’T SEE THE PROBLEM?
AND BY THE WAY, WHY NOT DO A
PRESS CONFERENCE ONCE IN A WHILE
INSTEAD OF THE T-BALL SESSION
THAT SHE DID ON CNN YESTERDAY?
I ALWAYS HEAR THE EXCUSE "
"VICE PRESIDENT DON’T HOLD PRESS
CONFERENCES."
THAT’S FUNNY.
I WOULD SEE MIKE PENCE ON MY
SCREEN, TAKING QUESTIONS FOR
EXTENDED.
MYS OF TIME WHEN HE WAS PUT IN
CHARGE OF THE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE.
THIS COULD BE HER SIGNATURE
FAILURE.
I COULD REALLY HURT HER CHANCES
IN 2024 IF JOE BIDEN DECIDES
THAT HE DOESN’T WANT TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AGAIN.
>> Emily: SO, KENNEDY, TAKING
THAT A STEP FURTHER, I THINK IT
IS CLEAR THAT WE ARE SEEING THE
STRATEGY OF PROTECTION BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAUSE ANY
TIME THE PRESS ADDRESSES HER NEW
ROLE AT THE BORDER, THEY SAY NO,
IT IS ONLY ABOUT THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE.
NO, IT IS ABOUT FINDING THE ROOT
CAUSES.
THERE IS A CLEAR CHASM BECAUSE
DOMINIC BETWEEN WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING SO THAT SHE CAN KEEP HER
RECORD CLEAN.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Kennedy: THIS TECHNIQUE IS
NOT WORKING.
IT IS SIMPLY NOT WORKING TO
PRETEND THAT THE SURGE AT THE
BORDER ISN’T HAVING A HORRIBLE
EFFECT ON CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
IT IS.
THERE IS SO MUCH CONFUSION, AND
THE ONLY SIGNALING FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS IF YOU SEND
YOUR KIDS ALONE, SELL EVERYTHING
YOU’VE GOT, SEND YOUR KIDS WITH
SMUGGLERS, WE ARE NOT GOING TO
SEND THEM BACK.
THAT MAKES THESE KIDS PAWNS IN
THIS ENTIRE ENTERPRISE AND PUTS
ON THAT SO MUCH RISK.
I DON’T THINK SHE UNDERSTANDS
WHAT WORD SHE IS USING WHEN SHE
SAYS "I CAN’T GET THERE SOON
ENOUGH."
THAT IS NOW.
NOW IS WHEN THE SURGE IS
HAPPENING.
IT IS ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE
AND WORSE, SO GO FIX IT NOW.
YOU CAN ABSOLUTELY WORK ON NOT,
BUT GO DOWN THERE, GET AFFECTED
BY APPEARED GET ANGRY IF YOU GET
EMOTIONAL.
SEE WHAT’S HAPPENING WITH THESE
KIDS, AND THEN DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
SHE IS NOT GOING TO BE ON SPIRIT
AIR.
SHE IS FULLY VACCINATED.
SHE WILL FLY ON THE PLANE WAS
LIKE FOR OTHER PEOPLE.
SHE IS LIKE THE JOHN KERRY OF
VICE PRESIDENT.
[LAUGHS]
>> Emily: KAYLEIGH, KENNEDY
MENTIONS THAT THE CHILDREN ARE
BEING USED AS PAWNS, AND WE HAVE
HEARD OF THE HORRORS AND
ATROCITIES THAT THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH.
PACKED IN LIKE SARDINES.
HOWEVER, THEY ARE BEING GIVEN A
BOOK.
EVERYONE IS BEING GIVEN A COPY,
APPARENTLY, OF VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS’ BOOK.
MY QUESTION IS WOULD THERE BE
ANY ACCEPTANCE OF THIS THAT
THERE IS NOW IF THIS HAD BEEN
HAPPENING UNDER THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION?
AND WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THESE KIDS GETTING "SUPERHEROES
ARE EVERYWHERE?"
>> Kayleigh: ONE OF THE LINES
IN THIS BOOK THAT THESE CHILDREN
ARE RECEIVING IS "IN TIMES OF
TROUBLE, SUPERHEROES ALWAYS SHOW
UP HERE" THE SUPERHERO,
KAMALA HARRIS, HAS NOT SHOWN UP
FOR THESE GIRLS IN THE MICRO AND
FACILITY IN HOUSTON THAT HAD TO
BE SHUT DOWN BECAUSE THEY HAD TO
USE THE BATHROOM AND BACK SPHERE
THEY WERE NOT ALLOWED TO
STAND UP FROM THEIR BEDS.
THE SUPERHERO DID NOT SHOW UP
FOR THEM.
FOR THE FOUR AND 5-YEAR-OLDS CUP
I SMUGGLERS.
THE SUPERHERO DID NOT SHOW UP
HERE THE SUPERHERO DID NOT SHOW
UP FOR THE KIDS WHO ARE VICTIMS
OF VIOLENCE.
AS THEY MAKE THE DANGEROUS
JOURNEY.
SUPERHEROES ARE NOT SHOWING UP
BECAUSE OF COVID, SHE SAYS.
WHAT A LAME EXCUSE.
IT IS PERFECTLY SAFE FOR HER TO
GO DOWN THERE.
EVEN IF YOU PUT ASIDE THE FACT
THAT SHE IS VACCINATED, WE
TALKED ON THIS PANEL, OUR
FRONT-LINE WORKERS DID NOT STOP
WORKING DURING THE PANDEMIC.
OUR POLICE OFFICERS DID NOT.
WHY IS IT FAIR FOR THE HIGHEST
OFFICE IN THE LAND TO NOT SHOW
UP?
IT IS AN EXCUSE, AND IT IS QUITE
SAD.
>> Harris: BECAUSE SHE DOESN’T
KNOW WHAT TO DO.
[LAUGHS]
IF YOU DON’T HAVE THE ANSWER,
YOU CAN’T RUSH TO THE BORDER.
WHAT ARE YOU RUSHING FOR?
THAT HAS GOT TO BE A PART OF THE
CALCULATION.
IF THEY WANT TO FILL IN THE GAP,
TAKE A NEWS CONFERENCE.
YOU CAN TELL US WHAT THE TRUTH
IS.
>> Emily: RIGHT.
BE TRANSPARENT.
COMMUNICATE.
BUT TO KAYLEIGH’S POINT, THE
VICE PRESIDENT ASKED IT HERSELF.